so i took a look at some questions from
a korean
university entrance exam and i was
pretty shocked by
how hard they were this is the csat
and i guess it's the south korean
version of the american sat
which you may be more familiar with but
i think this korean exam
ranks as much more difficult and is
right up there with some of the world's
toughest exams
it is taken by korean high school
students and the score determines
which university they can go to it is
very competitive
because many in korea believe that a
university's ranking
makes a huge difference to one's career
prospects
to get into those top unis you might
only be able to get one or two questions
wrong on the whole exam
but that becomes seemingly impossible
when you realize that the exam covers
five different topics on one day and
takes over eight hours to complete
i think one of the most difficult
sections is mathematics
it covers calculus with limits
derivatives
integration trig calculus even
integration by parts
plenty of conic sections vectors dot
products
3d geometry probability and statistics
and students would get three to four
minutes to solve
each question for question 15 we are
told
that two functions y equals a to the x
and y equals root three meet at the
point a
there's also this point b which is at
four zero
and we're asked what is the product of
all the values
of the little a such that the straight
lines
a b and o a
are perpendicular to each other now if
you ask me
that sounds pretty tricky i heard the
notorious questions hide near the end
so let's check out question 30 on this
2020 paper
what it says is that we have these two
functions one is a log
and one is an exponential and they meet
at
only one point when little a
can be said to be f of t it's a function
of this variable t
then we're asked to find the square of f
prime when t is equal to one-third
have a think about what you might want
to do here i'll come back at the end
and show my version of a solution but
first
let's look at some other sections
there's also
korean english history science
and some other optional papers the
english test starts off with a listening
section
and for this the whole country goes
silent
no planes take off or land in south
korea for that 30 minute period
so that shows how seriously this exam is
taken
for this recent question they had to
listen to what seems like a youtube
intro
and identify the purpose of the
paragraph
but later in the english section the
questions get a lot more abstract
with language that even a native english
speaker would find intense
there's a question about an african
proverb till the lions have their
historians
tales of hunting will always glorify the
hunter
and there's this paragraph here asking
us about the fact that
people don't usually think of touch as a
temporal phenomenon
but it is every bit as time-based as it
is spatial
the physics paper contains all the usual
suspects
but seems mostly based on conceptual
understanding
rather than heavy calculations
understanding
an eclipse how to determine the
wavelength of a laser
and orbital mechanics
here is just a glance at chemistry
biology and geology
and astrophysics
500 000 students take the exam each year
but around 20 of those are people taking
it again
because they weren't happy with their
previous score
those students may keep studying for the
same exam
year after year until they can get into
a good university
and move on with their life south korea
is an extremely well-educated country
their performance as well as enrollment
and graduation rates
are ranked among the top few in the
world they have around 80 percent of
high school graduates
going on to university so it may come as
no surprise that there is also
a booming private coaching industry
centered around passing this exam
they call them hagwons or cram schools
so let's take a look back at that math
problem it seems you first have to be
smart enough to figure out that if our
two functions would look like this
for the exponential and this for the log
that if they touch at only one point it
would be something like this
where the functions are tangent and do
not intersect
so we could set our function 1 equal to
function 2
to find that point where they touch that
will give us this
star equation here but that doesn't
immediately take us any further
instead we need a bit of a brain wave
that we can also
set the derivatives that is d y d
x equal to each other because at this
point
since they're tangent the slopes of each
line would be equal
so we can differentiate each side and
set them equal
noticing that our right hand side hasn't
changed during this process
we can replace it with the definition we
had for it earlier
giving us a version without any a and
just t's and
x's which can simplify down to give us
that
all of this is equal to one and i'll
call that
square because we're also going to use
that later
this might seem like another dead end
but we have to remember that we're being
asked to find
f prime of t which i prefer to think of
as d a d t and how would we get a d
a d t well we could go back up to
a equation that we started with and if
we were to differentiate
both sides of this with respect to t
this little a
in here due to implicit differentiation
would give us a
d a d t term so that's how we can get it
i differentiate both sides of it with
respect to t
remembering that a is a function of t
a bit of product rule a bit of chain
rule and you'll end up
with this now we're getting good at
replacing this term in here which crops
up again
i'm going to replace it with the result
of that initial differentiation
so i'll end up with this line here
now really we want to get d a dt by
itself since that's what we're
interested in
we can get rid of some of these terms by
multiplying both sides by
x minus t over t cubed and also
remembering that earlier we found
that all this was merely equal to one
because
that crops up right here we'll set that
equal to one
that simplifies things down quite a bit
a little bit more rearranging and we get
something for
d a d t which is the same as what
they're calling
f dash of t and because they wanted
f dash of t at t is equal to one third
we can put in one third for our value of
t
giving the minus eight and then they
want all of that squared
so that would be sixty-four perhaps the
calculus and algebra involved here
is not that advanced but the way that
it's arranged and the fact you need to
keep going back to results you found
earlier and somehow knowing how to get
your way out of these seemingly dead
ends
does make this problem really difficult
certainly a stretch to be able to do
this in just three or four minutes
and remember for this exam just thinking
that you can skip questions that are too
hard
is not really a feasible option if you
want to get those top scores
because getting just one or two wrong on
the whole thing
can actually make the difference if you
want to rank at the top
i think you're expected to be able to do
all of them best of luck to all
students studying for this exam or a
similar one
thanks for watching this video and you
can check out others in the playlist to
see how other countries might do things
thanks to my patreon supporters for
making this video possible
and a special shout out to today's
patron cat of the day
maeve